et on parle de la côte d'ivoire avec et
rodrigue connaît sociologues et
analystes politiques et chercheurs à
l'africaine security secteur network
bonjour andric connaît merci de répondre
à nos questions au saut la situation
rappelle celle de 2010 qui avaient vu
une partition du pays et des
affrontements violents
est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter de
l'arrestation de pascal affi n'guessan
qui fait suite à celle du numéro deux du
pdc y oui tout à fait nous sommes bonnes
soldes et radicalisation des positions
parti au pouvoir et qui inquiète dans la
mesure où le régime alassane ouattara on
va dire un truc pour te prends installé
au pouvoir et cette radicalisation à vis
de l'opposition pose problème en termes
de paix puisque ça ça risque de
christian nouveau l'environnement social
en 2010 l'élection de laurent gbagbo
n'avait pas été reconnu par la france et
la communauté internationale qu'en est
il pour alassane ouattara en 2020 et il
faut dire qu'il ya une attitude de
prudence au niveau international
c'est vrai que on assiste à une sorte de
deux stratégies de la communauté
internationale où on voit qu'elle est
c'est moins handrich de reconnaître
cette élection de monsieur alassane
ouattara on a des petits problèmes de
siège de l'ex connais je me permets de
vous de vous proposer une autre question
pour rétablir un petit peu la connexion
on parlait de la communauté
internationale en 2010 par exemple la
france était intervenue de façon
militaire avec l'opération licorne est
ce qu'elle peut à nouveau le fer est ce
qu'on peut s'attendre à une nouvelle
intervention dans soit française
internationale pense que l'emploi
l'environnement sécuritaire et politique
est totalement différent à nous ne sont
pas dans cette même c'est vrai que nous
sommes dans une situation de crise post
électorale où se font face à face deux
acteurs l'opposition qui ne reconnaît
pas du tout l'élection et le parti au
pouvoir s'est également qui campe sur
ses positions mais sera la situation
n'est pas comparable à celle de 2010 où
on a vingt pays par questionnaires avec
deux armées
avec la communauté internationale qui
n'avait plus fait du coup monsieur
alassane dramane ouattara
donc nous sommes là dans une situation
je pense qu'un peu plus différente où le
besoin premier objectif premier serait
de créer un environnement des
négociations entre les deux acteurs du
sort pour apaiser les tensions sociales
et on peut avoir des négociations
justement quand on voit que pascal affi
n'guessan est arrêté ça semble compromis
non tout à fait on constate une
radicalisation c'est vrai de la position
du gouvernement qui certes ne veut pas
justement à cette situation de 2010 ou
laissez pas respirer un peu plus voici
le bicéphalisme qu'on avait subi en 2010
mais à notre avis cette posture est
moins rentable pour la cohésion sociale
pour la paix sociale que si un dialogue
un dialogue et un entamé les chances de
dialogue sont possibles à notre avis il
y à des acteurs comme on l'a dit le
président laurent gbagbo par exemple
peut être un acteur le trait d'union qui
pourrait entre le parti au pouvoir
actuellement et l'opposition apaiser les
choses et il lancé un environnement de
la sirène de négociations merci
rodrigues connaît d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
sociologue analyse politique et
chercheur à l'african security secteur
network